Davos is a grift and a cult but it's
also a bid for global domination I wish
it were a conspiracy because then it
would be a lot quieter it's so loud it's
also basically pay to play if you pay a
million dollars the expectation is that
you get to be on stage and by the way
one of the discoveries that we pointed
out is that they're not transparent at
all about how they use their own money
but yeah they want control I mean you
kind of have a sense of it they want to
make it expensive to buy to use energy
they want to make it more expensive or
hard to eat meat they do want to
encourage more consumption of insects
they do want to encourage that you don't
own as much they you know want to
um you know basically exercise a kind of
Elite control over food and energy
production and not just a lead but
really European
um control over how countries produce
food and energy funny because World
economic form will be like these are all
conspiracy theories and it's like well
no they're actually from your website
[Music]
to Michael moving on because we could
quite easily do the entire interview on
this but moving on let's talk about the
whf let's talk about Davos let's talk
about the great reset I have
intentionally avoided this because I am
cynical enough about what is happening
the powers that be unaccountable leaders
etc etc
is this an exaggeration by people on
social media saying that these people
they're you know their modus operandi's
in 10 years we're all going to be living
on insects what is going on yeah
I love the story so um I think that my
view can be summarized in the headline
of the piece that I did with Isabella
kaminska as a former Financial Times
Reporter who had done
um real investigative reporting into the
finances of Davos
and what we said was
um
uh Davos is a grift
and a cult but it's also a bid for
global domination
and that basically summarizes my view of
world economic forum and Davos which and
it really mirrors a bit of the thinking
that we developed in Apocalypse never
which is that what's driving this
apocalyptic and malthusian pro-human pro
scarcity anti-human environmentalism is
really money power and religion and so
what you see is so one question is then
is it a conspiracy and I was joking I
was like I wish it were a conspiracy
because then it would be a lot quieter
it's so loud you know I mean I won't
this summer I had heard about the
insects thing and I was like well that's
really I mean that's crazy you know they
they don't really I was like I went and
just Googled World economic forum and
insects and I was like I couldn't
believe how many articles and videos
they had promoting eating insects by the
way I've eaten insects I eat I eat uh
the pupa that they eat in the bar in
Korea
um and it was disgusting and the Koreans
for them it's like a novelty the no
notably people are pretty drunk when
they eat those bugs and my wife who's
Korean asked her father about it and he
was like he's like basically he was like
we ate bugs after the Korean War because
he was a boy during the Korean War
because we were starving
you know and so when you so there's this
all this kind of crazy weird like insect
stuff it's like what's going on you know
um you know there is a there is a
somewhat conspiratorial aspect of it but
it's not really what people think it's
more just sort of getting Insider
information on what new companies
products they have and who's going
public but it's very ideological I mean
it's just I mean look you know what we
all know what world economic forum is
it's malthusians these are people that
think there's too many people in the
world they think that we all need to
return to pre-industrial Technologies
they don't want us to eat meat they
promote vegetarianism you know and some
of the reasons you know Michael can I
just interrupt you there because I don't
think a lot of people know what the
world economic forum is this is just
something that they've been here they've
seen on the internet they've been told
it in a pub in a book and look let's
steal man the argument a little but I
think that you you're obviously
describing some of the things that they
say but from their perspective wouldn't
to be fair to say that what is driving
their agenda is they believe uh in the
imminent climate catastrophe the the
world's about to end and if we don't act
globally because that is a global
problem that no one country or no set of
countries frankly can can solve uh then
we are in for a climate catastrophe and
what we need to do is get you know
people from government people from
business and people from other spheres
together in a place to talk about how to
solve these great problems facing
Humanity right and if you believe in in
the incoming imminent climate
catastrophe
then you know you're welcome there to
participate in the discussion about how
this should be solved and by the way
while we're fixing Global problems why
don't we get Tony Blair to talk about
how we need to register of who's
vaccinated or not and why don't we get
this and why don't we get that isn't
that really a more steel man version of
that argument
yes yeah and even to add a little bit
more Precision it's really about uh
bringing
um together policy makers and corporate
Executives to engage in dialogue and
free exchange of ideas
and to um and to encourage what's called
stakeholder capitalism meaning
corporations that are responsive not
just to their boards but to The Wider
public and that's something that I think
almost everybody believes we should do
now in practice it is not open to a
variety of different views it's highly
conformist that's what I mean about the
cult aspect of it yeah they do not allow
views like the views that I hold or
other people that you might call energy
or Environmental humanists
um they don't allow the idea that really
with abundant nuclear power and
desalination there is no climate crisis
because we can shrink the human
footprint and reduce our pollution with
nuclear it's very biased against nuclear
it's biased towards Renewables
um it's you know it promotes things like
eating insects rather than intensive
agriculture which can reduce how much
land is required for meat so it's
incredibly ideological pretending to be
open-minded it also pretends to be open
to various people but it's highly
exclusive it costs up to a million
dollars for a corporation to become a
partner it's also basically pay to play
if you pay a million dollars the
expectations that you get to be on stage
and so you start to see in the name of
transparency and by the way one of the
discoveries that we pointed out is that
they're not transparent at all about how
they use their own money we all we know
is that Al Gore manages some of it
that's as far as we were able to get
but you basically get
What's um called front running or or
kind of
um
creating new markets where basically you
go and get let's say the CEO of a new
insect company spends a million dollars
and he wants to be on stage
with you know a former prime minister
with a Tony Blair or a celebrity as a
way to kind of normalize and mainstream
something that most people have a lot of
ick Factor around so
um that's fine if you have transparency
that's a pay-to-play operation you're
paying for your public relations
basically but there isn't transparency
about it they hide that they also they
they engage in that kind of statement
that you were making Constantine around
oh it's about an open flow of ideas I'll
tell you the other is the corruption of
the media you know World economic Forum
um this is the event but we I think
maybe we've got to mentioned it takes
place in Davos you know at Switzerland
so
um but you know the news media are are
literally either paying or paid or both
to be there so you're getting this kind
of Relentless barrage of information
coming from these events but often you
know they entered into a financial
partnership with Reuters I mean here you
have a news media company that's acting
supposedly doing journalists but it's
really just public relations for a bunch
of for-profit companies paying to get on
stage
Michael so what what are they I guess
the question that an ordinary person
listening about the the Davos the WF the
great reset you know the what are they
up to in simple terms like why should I
give a [__]
I mean control you know I mean this is
sort of where I mean the conspiracy
theorists on the right who have been
kind of like it's this great reset it's
conspiracy they want to make you eat
insects rather than meat they want you
to the other famous one was
um uh I'll own nothing and be happy
which you know the great reset I mean
it's funny because World economic form
will be like these are all conspiracy
theories and it's like well no they're
actually from your website or from the
conference itself you know including but
yeah they want control I mean you kind
of have a sense of it they want to make
it expensive to buy to use energy they
want to make it more expensive or hard
to eat meat they do want to encourage
more consumption of insects they do want
to encourage that you don't own as much
that you are mostly renting or that you
don't have assets they you know want to
um you know basically exercise a kind of
Elites control over food and energy
production and not just a lead but
really European
um control over how countries produce
food and energy and you know it's it's
requires pushback from populist
movements you know demanding cheap
energy because that's the basis of one
of the bases of civilization it's also
really harmful in places like Africa
where where Nations have corrupt leaders
who and are less able to resist demands
that they you know use solar panels
rather than coal which is simply imp not
possible to develop with so you have I
think real Sinister implications on
developing developing economies and
potentially you know kind of control and
discomfort imposed on developed ones and
how concerned should we be because like
you know a bunch of people getting in a
room somewhere and having crazy ideas
happens all the time like that I get in
a room with people and we have crazy
ideas too but it's called trigonometry
exactly
uh so uh how in I mean some of the
people involved are influential and
powerful and Wealthy Etc uh should we be
concerned I guess is what I'm asking
I mean it's funny I think the thing I'm
most concerned about is the propaganda
that comes out of them I mean you know
half of all people you know some are
doing 30 to half say that you know
climate change will lead to human
extinction you know you have children
suffering anxiety disorders believing
that their very existence threatens the
polar bears or that we're having you
know in fact environmental Trends most
of them are going in the right direction
you know we're moving from coal to
natural gas it's been reducing carbon
emissions in every rich country globally
they were basically flat over the last
10 years we're protecting more
endangered species around the world the
places where endangered species are
threatened is often from Renewables I
mean these are really there's like you
know I've surveyed the public I used
Google survey to survey the public in
terms of things they believe and they
believe the misinformation and so yeah
for me this kind of circles back to I
think where the conversation started
which is that I think the real concern
is the misinformation coming from the
mainstream news media media about the
nature of these threats I think the
political right has done itself a
disservice by just going too far in
almost every case climate change is real
it is something we should do something
about it's not an apocalyptic threat
um you know there is a role for solar
panels I have them right over here
they're not able you can't you can't
lift people out of poverty with them you
know
um insects you know may be fine if you
can safely grind them up into powder and
sneak them into some food products maybe
that's okay there should be disclosures
about it it should not be forced on
people
um but it's not going to be an
alternative to meat and nobody I mean
the Koreans prefer beef too so you know
I I think like there's just some amount
of like it's just actually it's about
the misinformation more than the
conspiracy so it's like I appreciate the
way that like the conspiratorial right
has made the world economic Forum a kind
of focusing device for a lot of bad
malthusia in efforts which frankly at
the United Nations level are just as
terrible or in the U.S Congress are just
as terrible or in the British Parliament
are terrible really uniform provides
including this character the head of IT
Klaus Schwab who literally looks like a
James Bond villain it provides a
focusing device for Ordinary People it
provides some frisson for people like
Russell Brand and Glenn Beck and others
on the right to make a big deal of but I
think the bottom line is it's a it's
it's just espousing a really terrible
anti-human ideology that we need to push
back against
and what is the great reset and is that
just something that they talk about or
is that likely to happen in some shape
or form I mean to some extent the great
reset I mean according to them of course
they published a book on and they talk
about it always meant basically
accelerating the transition from fossil
fuels to Renewables so that's the you
know and then you kind of go is it going
to happen well no because we can't power
the world on Renewables
um so to some extent it's their own
Kool-Aid that they want you to drink you
know they think that the world you know
there's always been this apocalyptic
thing where it's religious right where
they go and Al Gore did it before Greta
and Greta did it before Extinction
Rebellion which did before just stop oil
which you know World economic Farm has
been there the whole time but it's kind
of like everybody's gonna realize that
we're out of harmony with nature and we
need to stop eating meat and use solar
panels and wind turbines and then we'll
come together and we'll come together as
a world and we'll have a kind of a
gentler Kinder capitalism and we won't
have War anymore and we'll be harmonized
with nature it's a kind of return turn
to the womb Bad Harmony ideology that
you know basically is replacing the
older judeo-christian framework with a
kind of woke green framework
hey Francis do you like locals I live in
London Mike so obviously no the only
place your I get from the locals is when
we show an intimate moment as we watch a
Japanese tourists get trapped in a tube
door that is good but I wasn't talking
about their locals I was talking about
our community on locals you mean the one
where you get phenomenal behind the
scenes content when you yeah
when you get wasp incredible guests like
Jordan Peterson Brett Weinstein Bill
Burr Sam Harris Adam Carolla Heather
Hein and others your questions not just
that you can get supporter only benefits
like trigonometry mugs monthly calls
with our other top supporters and even a
regular meal with me and Francis you
also get phenomenal behind the scenes
footage of our trip to America where we
met a whole host of incredible guests
and gave ourselves terminal indigestion
we're also starting to do monthly
giveaways for locals only the first one
will be signed copies of Andrew door's
new book plus you get access to an
incredible community of like-minded
people who share memes have fun
conversations and most importantly you
get to make new friends you can support
us with as little as seven dollars or
about five pounds a month or give us
more for the higher tier benefits go to
trigonometry.locals.com go to
trigonometry.locals.com and support the
show
Michael I've seen those part of the
right you uh the conspiratorial right
you call them and I and I agree with
that way of labeling them how much of
this comes down to the fact that
everybody went nuts over covered
and we we were put in lockdowns in my
opinion it was incredibly excessive
we couldn't really justify it when we
look at the effects both economic and
human that we're seeing now and people
on the right are seeing what happened
with kovid and they're thinking to
themselves well look somebody's got to
be in charge of this there needs to be
some grandiose plan it's them
oh for sure that had to play a part in
it I mean and because there is
centralized power right there is
governments that are making these
lockdown decisions the the the response
to covert initially I supported a pretty
strong response but clearly like it was
just obvious after a couple of months
that it wasn't what the elites were
treating it as and that we need to get
kids back in school and we were the
worst in California by the way my
daughter was kept out of school for
um a year and a half I mean huge Damage
Done to the most vulnerable kids my
daughter's fine but other kids suffered
much more so yeah I mean I think that
there's several people and I sh I share
the call you need something like a Truth
and Reconciliation Commission or kind of
like what the [__] was all that about
for the last three years you know right
um which is kind of like without it
being um without it continuing the cycle
of of kind of Revenge or something where
it's more just like what was that about
because you know I I know you guys are
interested I'm obsessed with the
psychology of all this and you had Josh
slocommon who talked about the cluster B
personalities on the left that hugely
resonates with my research just a lot of
anxiety disorders a lot of narcissism a
lot of psychopathy with demonstrated
within climate change movements I've
been documenting the narcissism of the
climate activists you know where it's
all like the world is going to end
because of me and it will be saved
because of me and there's a grandiosity
there there's also what psychologists
call splitting which is to see things as
black and white good or bad you see this
in Greta Tunbridge language all the time
same thing on covid you know you're a
coveted denier or you're a coveted
believer it's a real extremism
um so I think there's a kind of we're
going to take so we need to take some
time to get a perspective on
kind of you know how much was do people
go crazy because of covid how much of it
was kind of in the works because of
social media how much of it is due to
longer term Trends away from traditional
religion towards more secular
orientations which I think are anxiety
uh provoking in people who have a lot of
anxiety particularly some psychologists
argue that all anxiety is anxiety about
death including social anxiety fear of
social ostracism
um
you know how much of it is in the you
know
um you know in sort of the the move away
from globalization back towards more
National orientations I think we need to
spend some time unpacking all those
things and getting a clearer view of it
because I do think what comes out of it
potentially something very positive and
something very constructive which is a
you know to be on guard against
what you might call totalitarianism or
you might call it a kind of mass
psychopathy or this kind of
um I wrote it I was writing about slowly
yesterday where you know Matt taibi who
was one of the Twitter files guys and
was always skeptical of russiagate he
was like it felt like it just kind of
went crazy I mean there's something that
kind of Madness a kind of collective
Madness that took hold around covid but
we see it on climate change we see it on
trans issues you saw it on brexit we saw
it on Trump we actually people called it
Trump derangement syndrome
you know where it's like I have a close
uh friend relation who I said to her
um I was like there's just this evidence
of the Russia occlusion's not there and
she just goes well I just hate him so
much
you know and it's kind of like it's nice
because it was actually right so you
hate him so much
that you think that he did this bad
thing that he didn't do and I think just
being able to in that environment to
sort of surface it and go great let's
talk about that because then we can kind
of I think you're actually able to
loosen up some of that to kind of be
like I don't like Trump either but I
don't think he was like working for
Putin and and that's actually different
and you need to you need to go by the
[__] but I don't think this is
you know and if you can't disentangle
that then I think you've got some
trouble I think we can disentangle it I
think the moment to do that is now as
temperatures have come down a bit
you know I think even the fact this this
article I keep mentioning about about
from Columbia journals and reviews out
now
wasn't out a year ago even though you
probably could have published it a year
ago I think it's just that some thawing
is going on some truth telling is
occurring and hopefully some amount of
reconciliation I don't think we're going
to go back to that earlier form of
objective journalism but I do think we
might find ourselves to find more people
particularly people on the left able to
recognize the excesses of the last
several years yeah and when you were
talking about anxiety I mean one of the
things I actually did a and I was at an
event where Isabella kaminska he
mentioned Earl and I unheard we were
talking and I wasn't there to talk about
the great reset but it came up and I do
see this obsessiveness with the Auntie
it's not even the right necessarily it's
the kind of conspiratorial anti-woke
people yeah certainly to me seem to have
gone quite far it's almost like to them
you know the WF and class swap they're
kind of like the Press of page his CIS
heteronormative patriarchy
they're playing that role that they play
for the left an overarching system that
is responsible for all the problems that
you experience in your life yes um and
I'm kind of concerned about that because
it's it's a victimhood mentality
um you know it's it's kind of the same
thing in a way irrespective of the
Rights and Wrongs of of what people say
about the The Forum there is a
disempowering high anxiety neurotic
conspiratorial world view that I just
don't think is particularly healthy for
people uh and it's not constructive
right uh and I think what I'm interested
in in thinking about ways of how do we
how do we form a positive vision of the
future and you and I have been talking
privately about this as well it's like
we need a pro-human ideology of some
kind whatever that looks like and I I
certainly am not the person to come up
with it but there are some things that
we start to have to we have to start
going what are we for what do we believe
what is the counter Vision okay the
malthusians want to reduce the
population of the world to like a
billion or whatever and take it
backwards what do we want what what are
we for right
absolutely constant I mean I think it's
so important that I'm considering uh
going to London in a few months to have
this conversation I do think that um the
conversation that's occurring in Britain
right now and in the United States are
very similar and traditionally these are
great moments moments of change like
this are chances to kind of
um learn from each other and and I think
build that common platform you know for
me I you know I'm always inspired by you
know when when rock and roll got to
Baroque and crazy in uh you know it
there was a punk rock response and the
punk rock response was like okay you
have one guitar that's all one guitar a
drummer and a singer and that's it
that's all I mean Punk got crazy later
but for me I kind of go it's a punk rock
moment and you've got to get back to
basics so what is it that what is the
basics and I kind of go Basics is you
got to have a civilization you have to
have a civilization whether you're
liberal or conservative you know
conservatives are kind of trying to
prevent a lot of change and they want to
protect things so they're on team
civilization there's obviously the
radical left which is nihilistic and
anti-civilization in a lot of ways but
they're not the majority even of the
left I don't think you know they're
probably a third so you start to get a
coalition of the normies and I think
it's a pro-civilization coalition and I
would say three big things abundant
energy Law and Order and meritocracy and
on all three of those things you have
very large amounts of support on of the
public you have most of the right not
all of it but most of it and I think a
significant part if not most of the left
that means that abundant energy means
sure we're going to do some Renewables
but we need abundant natural gas and
nuclear or we're going to burn a lot
more coal Law and Order means you have
to enforce laws including laws against
loitering because that's how we prevent
sex trafficking human trafficking you
have to have laws against not sleeping
in public because that's how you get
homelessness or using drugs in public
because that's how you get addiction and
drug dealing
and you also but that means that's not
punishment either that's that's actually
enforcing laws and with an eye towards
Rehabilitation and then the third part
is meritocracy like the bridges have got
to be made by the best Engineers not by
people selected for their wokeness or
the bridges of people down you know um
or the or the pipelines are going to
explode or the math is not going to be
right so you've got to affirm those
three things at a minimum
and I think that then becomes the basis
for something and I think there's other
questions around things like you know uh
gender ideology and trans and are some
folks you know uh you know at what age
do people get to decide these things I
think we need to work out but in some
ways I just go we need to reaffirm you
know Free Speech these are some some of
the base that come I think return to
Basics and then start to answer some of
the harder questions like social media
regulation like like gender reassignment
surgeries and drugs issues where there's
some complexity there that is worth
working out but I think reaffirming that
pro-civilization position will
demonstrate that the anti-civilization
nihilists on the right or the left right
who don't want to be part of society are
really um are are more marginalized and
we can have a conversation uh that that
wins a majority of support Michael I'm
curious why you left out what I would
certainly add as a necessary plank of
that which is family and children is it
just so you didn't want to add an extra
or do you think that's a more
complicated conversation I think it's
much more complicated I think it's part
of that conversation that has to come
out but you know um not first of all not
everybody has a family
you know and and yet civilization has
got to be Universal it's not
civilization for some of us it's
civilization has always been everybody
gets to everybody follows the same laws
everybody has the same protections
whether they have a family or not now I
think there's a set of kind of
pre-political things that are important
definitely family I mean my family is
the most important thing for me so for
sure I couldn't be here if I hadn't been
raised in a particular way so I totally
believe in it I'm not sure how it
interacts with politics and I think that
at worst it ends up imposing a kind of
inappropriately imposing a kind of
morality that should not be imposed
um you know I'm really inspired by I
spent a lot of time talking about the
Netherlands but you could talk a lot
about a lot of Western European
countries but in the Netherlands
you're a citizen and so you have certain
rights it's very liberal it's always
been very Progressive on gay issues but
they're also you know the marijuana laws
are liberalized but the city is safe
they they don't allow open-air drug
dealing and I believe they're part of
this increasing backlash against
allowing miners to use puberty blocking
drugs and sex you know and gender
reassignment so I don't know for me I
kind of go
I don't know that's I think civilization
probably requires functioning families
I'm just not sure I would make it part
of that agenda because I think there's a
lot of ways to make a family and I think
I start to see some of the people that I
agree with on a lot of issues like
conservatives start to say you know you
know gay you know same-sex couples are
not families
um should not be allowed to adopt and I
start to get a little nervous about what
the implications of being pro-family are
Michael it's been an absolute pleasure
thank you so much for coming on the show
before we do our questions for locals uh
the last question we always ask is
what's the one thing we're not talking
about as a society that we really should
be and you're not allowed to say the
great reset
yeah I mean I would say even continuing
with the what we just talked about I
think the the I think one of the most
important insights that I've been I've
gained from my research is I think the
vast majority of people maybe everybody
needs some kind of faith and if you put
it in more psychological terms everybody
needs an immortality project everybody
needs some story they tell themselves
about how their lives matter and not
just in the lives that they're on Earth
but potentially after that and I think
recognizing that need that psychological
and spiritual need and having an open
conversation about it and encouraging it
for others to have that purpose in their
lives that you need that I think is
really liberating I think it helps to
answer and explain and understand why
we're seeing a lot of anxiety disorders
a lot of paranoia a lot of alienation
because people don't know that they're
actually pursuing through their politics
a spiritual project and that maybe if
they were more aware of that that really
they're bringing to climate change a
kind of apocalyptic religion
subconsciously that they would be less
dogmatic more tolerant
more open to being wrong and to
considering you know other ways of doing
things
and we can call it all lives matter
which I'm sure will bring everybody
together Michael
it's been an absolute pleasure I look
forward to seeing you when you're here
in London uh and we're going to do a
couple of questions that our supporters
have already submitted uh for you for
our locals that only they will get to
see but for now thanks for joining us
and thank you guys for watching and
listening we'll see you very soon with
another brilliant episode like this one
Aurora show all of them go out at 7 pm
UK time and for those of you who like
your trigonometry on the go it's also
available as a podcast take care and see
you soon guys
are you planning to run against us for
governor of California or are you going
for a 2024 bid as an independent
[Laughter]
[Music]